NARRATOR: In the
Montana backwoods--
Oh!
NARRATOR: --veteran
trapper Tom Moore
is battling the brush to
claim every last dollar
before the season closes.
My boots are slick.
NARRATOR: But the payday
doesn't come easy.
[music playing]
And finally, after a
two-mile fight to cross
nature's wild gauntlet--
We made it to the water.
NARRATOR: --he's reached
the promised land.
That looks beavery, too.
[music playing]
All right, we've got
a good set in here.
Let's go put some more traps in.
The slough is so big, it's
big enough to have two
or three beaver families in it.
NARRATOR: A single beaver family
can have as many as 12 members.
At $200 a pelt, Tom's
hard-fought gamble
could be a last-minute jackpot.
TOM: Then there's a tunnel
that goes underneath here,
and goes into that water
over on the other side.
Be an ideal place
for a trap there.
NARRATOR: Tom's an expert in
locating the high-traffic lanes
in this maze of interconnected
waterways, a skill he'll
need to maximize his catch.
[music playing]
TOM: And now it's up
in that tree there.
NARRATOR: A hard day's work
yields a surprising reward.
Well, that might be
an extra [inaudible]
NARRATOR: A rare 10-pound
porcupine with a valuable hide
and quills.
Think I'm gonna go
harvest the porcupine.
[music playing]
[bird squawking]
All right.
He's got good hair on him.
I can actually make
money from a porcupine.
I'll be able to
sell all the quills
I can harvest,
along with the hair,
and even the front toenails.
[music playing]
Now, this is a little added
bonus to the old trap line.
[music playing]
All right.
Years and years ago, before
the white man brought beads
to this country to
trade to the Indians
for decorative
stylings, the Indians
used dyed porcupine quills.
These are little
round rawhide rings,
and the quills are all
wrapped around them,
and the ends are all
glued on the back.
Lots of the war shirts
that the Indians wore,
like on the Plains,
would have one of these
mounted on the front of it.
NARRATOR: On average,
a single porcupine
has a staggering 30,000 quills.
Also, the hair
has a value to it.
The Native Americans used
this hair for what they
call roaches, dancing roaches.
It was a headdress
that they'd wear.
There's hours of plucking
on that porcupine
I've got to look forward to.
But we're not finished yet.
We've still got traps to check.
The season's gonna close in
a few more days, so that's
all we can do, is just try to
wrap up what we've got going
and bring in as
much fur as we can.
And it looks like another
successful season.
[music playing]